at this point in time you should have
already seen Iron Man's new
bleeding-edge armor suit and if you
haven't here's a link to more
information on it also if you're new to
my channel please be sure to subscribe
and join the wolf wolf pack we've gotten
a good look at it from some posters and
some magazine covers and we've also
gotten clips of it in action from the
trailers that have been released you
also may have caught the rocket mortgage
promo that came out a few days ago that
had Iron Man showing off some of his new
suits abilities the suit is quite
impressive and it looks like they're
going to be given it the same
characteristics that it has in the
comics the suit is made out of millions
of nano machines and the nano machines
can turn into whatever Tony thinks up
including massive weapons we've seen
some of these weapons in the comics
we've seen some in the trailers and
we've seen some in promo art and the
toys that have been released but the
question is will this new armor be
enough for Iron Man to defeat Thanos oh
let's discuss now we're all really
excited to see Iron Man's new
bleeding-edge armor suit on screen but
despite how cool and powerful it is this
is still fan oast that we're talking
about here so let's recap yeah and those
only has two of the Infinity stones at
this point and even with Iron Man's
bleeding-edge armor suit on he doesn't
seem to be doing too well not to mention
Spider Man who is believed to have the
same nanotechnology suit doesn't seem to
be holding his own either I also have
this scene here which is believed to be
Tony stranded on the planet Titan which
is where he fights Thanos as you can see
here his armor is completely destroyed
which is weird because a characteristic
of the bleeding-edge armor and the
nanotechnology inside of it is that it
can self heal the dantos punch him so
hard that his armor just gave up let's
watch it again
what more than likely happened here is
that Thanos used the power of the
Infinity stones that he currently has to
destroy his armor and again these are
just two Infinity stones a lot more
chaos and destruction comes when he
wields all of them what happens when he
wields all of the Infinity stones in the
Infinity Gauntlet you ask well to start
off he does in fact wipe out half the
universe but the snap of his fingers
like Gamora states in one of the
trailers and it does not end well for
the Avengers Thanos the mad Titan kills
Captain America just by backhanding him
he kills vision by ripping out his
internals he kills Thor by turning him
into glass and shattering him going
against Scarlet Witch who is arguably
the strongest Avenger if not one of the
strongest he uses his godlike powers to
turn scarlet witch's hex powers against
her killing her on the spot Thanos is so
powerful with the Infinity Gauntlet that
he actually defeats that cosmic beings
himself
so if Thanos can defeat Thor with great
ease and he can defeat Scarlet Witch
with great ease and he can defeat the
cosmic beings who are among the
strongest beings in the universe it's
not looking too good for Tony Stark
whether Thanos has two Infinity stones
or all of the Infinity stones or no
Infinity stones it doesn't seem like
Iron Man is much of a match for Thanos
this is why so many superheroes are
coming together for Avengers infinity
war to try to defeat Thanos Thanos is
probably the biggest villain that the
Avengers ever go against and I'm so
excited to see Avengers infinity war in
less than a month what do you think will
happen to Iron Man in Avengers infinity
war there's been a lot of speculation
that he will die what do you think do
you think he makes it out alive let me
know in the comments below and be sure
to like this video and subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date on Avengers
infinity war Marvel and all things
superhero
thank you so much for watching woof woof
you